(uplifting music)
- [Mutua] I think people are affected
by the images they see.
Most of the time that you
see images coming from Kenya,
specifically, in most of Africa,
it will be war, disease,
AIDS, famine, something like that.
While that is true,
there's still a lot more
coming out of the continent
that is uplifting,
that is positive, that is encouraging.
My mission is to change
our own perceptions
of what Africa is supposed to be.
(uplifting music)
My name is Mutua Metheka,
and I'm a photographer.
I got into photography by accident.
A friend of mine showed
me something on a website,
and I was like, I probably can do this,
so I decided to try it out.
(light uplifting music)
Originally, my mission was
to, you know, educate the West
on what Africa is like.
And I realized, it doesn't matter
what other people think, if
we still think of ourselves
as backward or not worthy.
So, my mission changed
to trying to get people
who have grown up in
African cities to learn
to see Africa differently.
If I can keep shooting
what I want people to see,
then I believe over time
this changes what people
think of themselves.
(upbeat music)
I have recently just
completed a project where
rock climbing communication masts
from all over the country.
The aim was to explore different views
from this new perspective.
(uplifting music)
I can almost guarantee that
no photographer in Africa
or in Kenya has photographed
from the heights
that I photographed from.
So it was a unique opportunity
and a very rare chance for me.
(uplifting music)
We traveled about seven/eight days,
climbed seven masts in total,
some going as high as 100 meters.
It was hard climbing,
but you get to the top,
and you see the view that awaits you,
and it's like another world.
(uplifting music)
It was beautiful being up there.
Photography has a unique way of being able
to change perceptions just
by seeing something different
over and over and over.
(uplifting music)
All of these things are
connected to the value
that you place on the
place that you live in.
I think if we see that
what we have is really
beautiful and worth protecting,
then we put a lot more
effort into protecting it
for ourselves and for the future.
(uplifting music)